Sim.
Um quantum circuit vai ser a unidade de valor
para o seu negócio — o qubit é a unidade de informação
mas um circuit é a unidade de computação
então vamos tentar entender o que é um quantum circuit
e vamos ver a sua anatomia
é assim que um quantum circuit parece
visualmente ele se divide em partes — os qubits
são representados por essas linhas horizontais; neste caso estamos representando
um circuit que tem quatro qubits como você vê
aqui agora os gates são
como controlamos os qubits
e você lê os gates da esquerda para a direita
e os gates de qubit único podem ser de qubit
único ou gates de múltiplos qubits
você vê ali o gate controlado
que é aquele que tem a linha entre dois dos qubits
e é aí que vai acontecer a operação de entrelaçamento
e por fim você tem a medição e a saída clássica
e muito importante: você executa um circuit muitas vezes
para obter o resultado com a noção de shots
e assim um contador de shots é o número de vezes
que você precisa repetir uma computação para obter o resultado
bem
como eles parecem
vamos ver como é um de dois bits
era a imagem de antes, certo — introduzindo uma mudança de fase
e eu mostrei antes uma operação que realizou aquela rotação
que permite fazer aquela operação de interferência
então vamos fazer uma comparação entre um circuit clássico
e um quantum circuit — num circuit clássico o que você
vai notar é que não há luas azuis, certo
não há rotações, tudo aqui é simples
e você tem os estados únicos
que nesses gates vimos anteriormente
mas repare no contraste que vai surgir
quando implementamos de fato um quantum circuit
esses são os circuits reais que executamos nos nossos computadores quânticos
que você também pode experimentar
os circuits que vamos criar
com a combinação dos gates
geram a amplitude complexa completa
que eu compartilhei com você
antes — por que isso é importante
porque agora podemos gerar essas relações complexas
entre os qubits em termos de fases
e entrelaçamento e então, pelo ato da medição
somos capazes de colapsar essa enorme quantidade
de computação que está acontecendo internamente em
alguma resposta importante
e é assim que chegamos finalmente a
à resposta — então colocamos lado a lado apenas visualmente
você pode ter uma noção de que um circuit clássico nunca pode
explorar o vasto espaço computacional
que um quantum circuit pode — é
a melhor forma de dar a você essa intuição
da riqueza com que podemos acessar esse grande espaço de estados.
E a parte bonita disso é que podemos
ter muitas classes de circuits para
realizar diferentes funções então
por exemplo este é um circuit
projetado para modelar risco financeiro
este é um exemplo de um circuit
usado para busca e otimização de problemas
e aqui está um exemplo de um circuit que é usado para
simular uma molécula — um ponto
importante é que você pode projetar diferentes circuits
para diferentes aplicações
os circuits que projetamos são então capturados
em software e mantidos como software
e no nosso caso os mantemos no Qiskit
que é o nosso kit de desenvolvimento open source para computação quântica
este é um dos frameworks de software
mais amplamente utilizados para computação quântica
e você pode imaginar construir
bibliotecas de circuits que são incorporadas em
programas clássicos que agora combinam o melhor da programação clássica
com o melhor do poder quântico